you know about the little British girl
Indie Gregory she was a baby who had a
disease and uh the UK government said we
don't want to pay for her medical
treatment anymore so we're going to kill
her and I had her father Dean Gregory
come on the show he was making a last
minute appeal to the courts sadly the
courts shot it down the Italian
government gave Indie Gregory
citizenship so the UK government
ultimately ended up killing an Italian
citizen which creates an international
legal crisis that will probably just be
brushed aside but it it seems
significant to me uh the Vatican offered
to treat baby Indie Gregory at the
benino Jesu hospital but the UK was so
embarrassed by this the UK couldn't
allow the baby to go seek treatment
elsewhere because that would be an
indictment on the UK it would be it
would be a global embarrassment that
some other government has to step in to
save a British citizen because the
British government just wants to kill
that citizen to save a few bucks even a
little innocent baby like Indie Gregory
now we knew this was the way the story
was almost certain to end from the very
beginning and that is what happened but
there there was one happy little turn
before the story before Indie Gregory's
Earthly story ended which is that Mr
Gregory the father had the baby
baptized and it's not as though Dean
Gregory was some devout practicing
Christian he has not been that in fact
that's what makes the story even more
powerful Dean Gregory says I'm not a
religious guy but but he says quote when
I was in court I felt as if hell pulled
at me I thought that if hell exists then
Heaven Must exist too I thought that if
the devil exists then God must exist too
I have seen what hell is like and I want
Indie to go to
heaven show me the flaw with that
argument that's a beautiful beautiful AR
argument that's
great some
people won't like this argument because
they'll say well you know no that's
you're you're not making a perfectly
rational argument for the existence of
God and for the historicity of the
gospels and for the this and it's not
neat and Pat and to no this is a great
this is a great ARG this is a much much
realer argument frankly because he's
saying you know yeah I'm not religious
at all and I I I can't recite to you
Thomas aquinus is five ways for knowing
the existence of God but I tell you what
when I was in that British courtroom and
that that evil judge was killing my
daughter I knew what evil was I knew
that evil exists I knew that evil has a
personality I could feel a rather
serious simulacrum of hell
and with all the devil's minations in
that courtroom he undid himself with all
the devil's minations he undermined
himself because it occurred occurred to
me that if the devil exists and if hell
exists then God in heaven must exist too
and God in Heaven Must Be much greater
than the devil in hell and so he had his
baby
baptized I to this I don't know what he
currently thinks about all these things
but he knew enough to say I am going to
do what I can to save my daughter even
the fact that he had to confront
something that most of us can push off
which is the fact of
mortality we're all going to end up in
the same place as Indie Gregory most of
us don't end up there at months old but
but we're all going to end up there at
some point and so it you know the silver
lining in that storm cloud which is
which is a stormcloud that we're all
going to face which is the fact of a
fallen world and our
immortality he was able to find that
silver lining there which is the
confrontation of death it's it's why uh
why Dr Johnson had a famous line which
is depend upon it sir when a man knows
he's to be hanged in in a fortnight it
concentrates the Mind
wonderfully say when we when we actually
have to face face the thing that we put
off as best we can for our entire lives
namely the fact of our death our
inevitable death it concentrates us and
it it doesn't confuse us what the
atheists and the Liberals want us to
believe is well it just has us
desperately grasping its straws and
wishcasting this notion that we can live
forever but it's really the opposite it
has us focus and say okay well what is
the meaning of my life what am I am I
just a bag of chemicals or am I
something more than that do my natural
desires and longings for something
Beyond this world point to something
that does exist Beyond this world do
does my natural intuition and deduction
of the metaphysical the fact that we
know we know for certain there are
things that are not merely physical in
this world like I don't know mathematics
the fact that there are metaphysical
things does that imply something more
about metaphysical reality and all of
that hit Mr Gregory like a ton of bricks
in that courtroom and the the the
personification of evil that he saw
occurring around him and to him and and
therefore the personification of good
ultimately ultimately a happy ending
albeit with much pain in the meantime
right now go to genus cell.com letter y
letter T our friends at genus cell have
launched a new product called genus cell
3 which works fast on your under eye
bags and puffiness Genia cell 3 is
smoother more luxurious and it uses
advanced technology to deliver complex
vitamins and minerals directly to your
face for instant hydration it is like
Gatorade for your skin this new genus
cell technology keeps skin looking young
and healthy for years to come the genus
cell fall Classics package also includes
a jawline treatment for a more firm neck
and jawline it also includes genus
cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer and
deep Firming Serum get your skin ready
for the cold and dry weather if you
don't look and feel your absolute best
you will get your money back no
questions asked go to genucell.com nyt
or you can call 800 skin skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package results in 12 hours or less the
immediate effects are included for free
by the way the founder of this company
great Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left there for the American dream so
head on over to Jus cell.com letter y
letter T or call 800 skin SK iin 211 now
speaking of this speaking of politically
motivated conversions I teased a story a
few days ago that I I do want to get to
at least briefly Ian hery Ali very
prominent political figure she was
raised Muslim she recoiled against that
she became an atheist and a big
anti-islam and Islam M campaigner and
she was a a very popular figure in the
west and remains a popular figure in the
west she's converted to
Christianity and she's done it in a way
that some Christians don't like she has
converted
politically she is converted sort of the
way that Indie
Gregory was converted through her Father
which is politically as a result of
political
events though though for ION hery Ali
it's even it's even more political in
that she says the reason that I'm a
Christian is because civilization cannot
withstand barbarism without Christianity
so she is she is describing Christianity
in a kind of instrumental way she says
why do I call myself Christian now part
of the answer is global Western
Civilization is under threat from three
different related forces the Resurgence
of great power authoritarianism and
expansionism in the forms of the Chinese
Communist party and Putin's Russia the
rise of global islamism political Islam
which threatens to Mo ize a vast
population against the west and the
viral spread of woke ideology which is
eating into the moral fiber of the Next
Generation she says we Endeavor to fend
off these threats in with modern secular
tools military economic diplomatic and
technological efforts to defeat bribe
persuade appease or surveil and yet with
every round of conflict we find
ourselves losing ground we're either
running out of money with our national
debt in the tens of trillions or we're
losing our lead in the tech race with
China we can't fight off these
formidable forces unless we can answer
the question what is it that unites us
the response that God is dead which
Nicha gives is insufficient so too does
the attempt to find solace in the
rules-based international liberal order
which is just a bunch of gobble deok
words that have not uh done very much
for us recently the only credible answer
says Ian her Ali lies in our desire to
uphold the legacy of the judeo-christian
tradition that is why I no longer
consider myself a Muslim apostate but a
atheist of course I still have a great
deal to learn about Christianity I
discover a little more at church each
Sunday but I have recognized my own long
journey through a wildness Wilderness
rather of fear and self-doubt that there
is a better way to manage the challenges
of existence and either Islam or
unbelief had to offer and and so there
are going to be Christians who criticize
Ali and say well you you shouldn't in
the same way that I just criticized
rapael waro you shouldn't just use
Christianity as some instrument toward a
political
end but where whereas for Raphael waro
that appears to be the the end of his
faith Journey while for Raphael waro
this is something that he has considered
for decades working as a professional
Christian he says no this is what
Christianity is about actually recoiling
against people whose Faith points to
something higher than politics for ION
hery Ali this is only the beginning and
she is admitting this here in the column
she's saying I have a lot to learn I'm
learning a little bit more every time I
go to church every time I read something
and so I'm learning but
what what she's saying is the political
is what pulled me into
Christianity not that I am a Christian
instrumentally so that I can achieve
certain political ends she's saying the
political problem is what first turned
me on to the fact that that all of these
other Solutions don't work and maybe
that's that's why Christianity has
something to recommend it maybe
Christianity even possibly is true
that's fine by me we live in a very
modern liberal individualist age and
modern
certainly a number of strains of modern
protestantism not all but but a number
of them are highly
individualistic and highly emotivist and
they'll say well you just need to be
feeling certain things individually
forget about the church forget about the
community forget about the reality of
sacraments just you got to just feel
stuff man going on inside of you and if
you don't feel it your faith is not real
that is not historically what Christians
have believed in fact there have been
whole communities and whole Nations that
have converted on
mass the political has often LED
conversion to the faith for goodness
sakes Armenia is the oldest Christian
country in the world the country
converted in what was it 31 or 310 it
was before the Edict of Milan legalized
Christian relaxed the the prohibitions
on Christianity throughout the Roman
Empire that was a that was a conversion
a number of the tribes that took over
the Roman Empire after the fall of the
Empire converted on mass Nations used to
be called Christian nations our
civilization used to be a Christian
civilization the political order does
not necessarily have to be totally
opposed to Christianity there does not
necessarily have to be a firm separation
of church and state in fact there never
has been for all of history anywhere in
the world not in this country not in any
other country the question is merely
what religion is animating your country
and your civilization right now in in
modern liberal culture we've returned to
worshiping the nature Gods just as they
did before the Advent of Christianity
and we say the ultimate threat is that
it won't rain this season so we have to
make a few more sacrifices and do a
little more of a rain dance put on our
our big rituals where we go March around
and dance and listen to a a Swedish
child yell at us and if we do that for
long enough then the nature Gods will
will smile and and show their favor to
us and we'll get rain for the Harvest
that's the that's the new religious
ritual that animates our civilization
it's a ridiculous one it's not going to
be conducive to to flourishing
personally or politically or we could go
back to the one that served us very well
for at least 1,700 years that's the one
that ion her allei is is realizing might
serve us well again man what a great
clip that was now hey hey hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NES YouTube channel we'll see
you next time